hi i got a 300 check from the government
and nvidia said i need to put it into a
video card so i can mine over the years
well that's fantastic a really smart
decision young gamer we can put that
money into an rtx 3060 video card and
we'll reinvest the earnings into
ethereum currency wallets with taking
interest and it's gone
uh what it's gone it's all gone
the video card it didn't do too well
it's gone
nvidia at this point has realized that
its products don't have to be exciting
they just have to exist the rtx 3060
is supposedly out today and supposedly
purchasable
and regardless of how true that
statement is we're going to be
benchmarking it and reviewing it we'll
be looking at thermal's
frequency and the validation of
frequency claims
specifically for the evga 3060 xc black
edition
this is supposed to be a 329 dollar card
so adjusted for inflation scalping and
bitcoin that's somewhere between
about 900 usd and
actually it's infinite there's actually
a floating point limit we hit
before the price stops rising so
somewhere in that range
and this card is uh it comes in below
the ti
obviously and previously the 2060
the 2060 super came out uh but the 2060
in particular is still kind of available
depending on what region you're in
and what manufacturers in your region
have decided to
keep some 2060 skus alive so that means
this is really between a ti
and a 2060 and that's what we're
focusing on most for today before that
this video is brought to you by asus
and the asus tough gaming b550 plus wifi
motherboard ready for amd ryzen cpus
the tough gaming b550 board comes in atx
and micro atx variants
with key features including a wi-fi 6
module
2.5 gigabit ethernet a fanless chipset
heatsink for quiet operation
and a focus on stability and up time
learn more about the tough gaming b550
plus wi-fi motherboard at the link in
the description below
basic overview for the 30-60 then so 330
dollars
is around where the price floor should
be it's 35 84
cuda cores if we're going to use
nvidia's marketing speak as compared to
the 360 ti
which runs 4864. it's over a 30
difference or so but it's not a one to
one percentage change in gaming
performance depends on what you're doing
memory is the most interesting so the
3069 ti
is running 12 gigabytes of gddr6
as compared to eight gigabytes on the
360 ti
also gddr6 but there's a a memory
interface change
so this is 192 bit whereas the other is
256. that means that memory bandwidth is
reduced on the non-ti
and to be very clear here amd is 16
gigabytes of memory on the rx 6800
series
is basically marketing you don't need
that memory you will not benefit from it
in gaming scenarios versus say 12. or in
a lot of cases eight
depending on the resolution you're
playing the texture quality things like
that but
12 will get by pretty well the reason a
company might choose 16 versus 12 or
whatever the case may be 10 11 is
largely it boils down to how many memory
controllers are on the die
on the silicon and the architecture of
the memory subsystem which we've all
talked about in the past
but 16 versus 12 for modern gaming
not particularly useful where amd's 16
gigabyte frame buffer comes really in
handy
is if you're doing a lot of 3d art
something like blender it can easily use
that memory and we've seen it firsthand
when andrew puts together some of the
actually really cool
uh 3d art that we've been working on
lately we've seen the memory get used
but for gaming not particularly useful
so 12 versus 8
falls into the same category where you
are going to become
bound by other things on the gpu first
rops for example and the ability to
stretch to 12 gigabytes actual
utilization on this
outside of 3d art in gaming it's very
unlikely you're probably going to hit
some other limitations first
and that's fine but the reason i bring
all of this up is that
nvidia is putting 12 on this to combat
amd on marketing
nvidia might know something that we
don't know yet about amd's next card
whatever is going to be competing with
the 3060 and the 3060 ti
and they might have decided based on the
information they know or they think they
know
that 12 gigabytes will do a lot better
job marketing and selling this
particular card
then if they drop down to eight or more
likely six is probably what this would
have been
when compared to amd's price to price
competitor in the future so anyway that
out of the way
the 12 gigabytes is genuinely very
interesting because it creates a really
screwy
hardware stack where instead of just
going like that it's just a
line segment straight up uh you get
memory capacity on a chart that looks
more like this
and we haven't really seen that before
for performance we'll be looking at
standard gaming performance
rasterization performance and ray
tracing performance
we are not looking at rbar for this one
we've looked at our bar before
particularly with the 6800 and xt
launches
and that's in a separate bench video if
you want to see the
amd rx series performance with resizable
bar
but because amd and nvidia aren't
competing in the same price class
we're looking at it in a standard bench
and then we'll come back for rbar
later with nvidia uh just because well
this has got enough content
in it already okay let's get into the
review we'll start with some frequency
and thermal validation go into the
performance and talk
if it's worth it or not we'll start with
frequency validation to determine
how the rtx 3060 performs at a lower
level
there's no fe model so we're using the
xc black as
baseline with emphasis that any more
advanced cooling features
or higher power targets in v bios would
flatten or heighten the frequency line
as a result of those changes
the rtx 3060 fe plotted a jumpy line
between about 1900 megahertz and 1990
megahertz
the fact that it's jumpy is normal for
gps dating back to at least pascal
but it means that we're bouncing off of
various limiters in this instance it's
power
but every couple of degrees will also
cost about 12 or
15 megahertz per tick the rtx 3070 ran
overall lower frequency
in the range of 1850 to 1930 megahertz
this is typical of a larger class gpu
it's obviously the better card despite
the lower frequency but that lower
frequency is what allows it to run a
bigger core or is at least part of it
as for the rtx 3060 non-ti this model
produces
a perfectly flat line that's not because
the 3060 gpu silicon itself is somehow
magical it's because of the 3060 xc
black specifically this model of card we
don't have much of the usual
initial frequency decay that's
experienced from a gpu warming up and
that's thanks to the cooler
the 3060xe black holds 1905 megahertz
for the
entire burn and generally speaking we do
actually prefer to see this behavior
it's easier to overclock this way too
and it's easier to predict
but it's often limited to cards with a
high enough power target that something
else becomes the limiter first like
for example voltage thermal's at steady
state position the rtx 3060 xc black at
about 64 degrees celsius
and that's tested in a 21c constant
ambient temperature but this isn't delta
t value
64 is good and typical of an evga
temperature target
but remember that an auto controlled fan
or auto controlled temperature
doesn't really tell you too much it just
tells you what the v bios temperature
target is
and in this case it's 64. that's not
necessarily
an indicator that the cooler itself is
good you have to look at fan speed for
that
hotspot temperature ran at about 75 c
also
fine fan speed sat at about 1900 rpm
which is
average among video cards we've tested
lately particularly these evga
xc models overall the xc black looks
okay here we'll defer to our tear down
video separately
for more qualitative analysis of the
cooler assembly and that'll go up
after this one total war 3 kingdoms at
1080p had the rtx 3060 at 71 fps average
positioning it just above the gtx 1080
and rtx 2060 ko stock carts the rtx 2060
super held about the same performance as
the 3060
but the 2060 super wasn't particularly
exciting to begin with when it launched
so
not great positioning generationally the
rtx 3060 has improved over the rtx 2060
and the ko for example which is the 2080
cut down
that was priced at about 300 so that
performance
uplift is 11 here that's not great
for a 10 increase in price with the 30
60.
we typically like to see more than a one
to one generational improvement with
price increase otherwise there's not
actually any progress the 3060 ti offers
a 30
uplift over the 30 60 non-ti at a 20
price hike for instance
the 5700 xt also outdoes the 3060 by
about 8.6 percent here although it lacks
other features like ray tracing hardware
that are present on amd and nvidia cards
from this generation
overclocking wasn't bad on the 360xc
black the improvement was about 7
with low is also improving at a
disproportionately positive pace so
that's
a nice change but seven percent isn't
too different from what we've seen
on other cards for this past generation
at 1440p
the rtx 3060 drops to 44 fps average and
maintains the same 11
spacing from the 2060 ko as before
and the 3060 ti maintains a similar 32
lead over the 3060 as at 1080p
the 3060 would make sense for most games
at 1440p but our graphics settings are
high enough here that it'd be ideal to
run a card class to 1080ti
and up the 2060 super is again about the
same as the 36 the albeit slightly ahead
amd's closest option is the 5700 xt but
until
amd has something of a 300 class the
6800 remains significantly distant
in price and performance alike 4k
plunges the rtx 3060 predictably down
the ranks but overall spacing is similar
to previously
it's ahead of the 2060 identically at 11
as before
and between the gtx 1080 and rx 5700 xd
this isn't really a card for 4k gaming
in most instances
but it'll work in some like maybe csgo
or rainbow six each the reason we
included it here is to see if the
percent difference scaling changes at
all
but that's not so for other recent rtx
cards
as the arc is actually remains the same
between the current generation
and similar enough to the past
generation that spacing is similar
amd stumbles a little bit at 4k when
compared to 1080p
with its newer offerings but the 6800
and xt just like the 3070 3080
aren't particularly relevant for this
price class they do offer some
perspective if your budget increases
or if one falls off the back of a gpu
scalping truck we run strange brigade
with both vulcan
and dx12 but the hierarchical scaling is
mostly the same between the two of them
in this 1080p test the rtx 3060 ended up
at 165 fps average
with lows at space proportionately and
without any major frame time spikes the
3060 ti keeps a 29
lead over the 30 60 here with the 5700
xt about the same as the overclocked xc
black 3060 and the overclocked 3060
offered a 7 leap over the 30 60 not
overclocked
thus far most of the percentages are the
same as previously there's one
meaningful change on this chart
and it's that the 3060 is now 17 ahead
of the 2060
versus 11 in previous tests that's at
least
more meaningful than in total war the
2060 super is again about the same as
the rtx 3060 here at 1440p
the 3060 slightly increases its lead
over the 2060 and scales to a 20
lead the 3060 ti maintains the same 29
spacing over the 3069 ti and the 3060 oc
keeps about the same seven
to seven and a half percent improvement
older gpus particularly the 10 series
and
back should slip further down the
relative rankings as the resolution
increases
and the same is true of amd gpus the key
difference is that modern amd gpus will
scale disproportionately well
at 1080p and 1440p to some extent which
may mean that amd will be particularly
competitive at these lower price classes
where 1080p remains the most relevant
solution of course
until a card in that price class exists
from amd there's nothing to talk about
at 4k the rtx 3060 holds on at 70fps
average a testament more to the asura
engine than anything else
the card falls just below the rx 5700 xt
which is flanked by the 360 oc results
at 74fps average the same 7
jump as before over the stock result
compared to the rtx 2060 ko
the 3060 is about 24 the heck and
compared to the 2060 super it's again
roughly the same so it's at least better
than we saw in total war
versus the 2060 ko but if you end up
with a super card previously there's
really nothing to upgrade to
rainbow six siege is a popular
competitive title that
also happens to spew frames at 1080p the
rtx 3060 holds 288 fps average marking
it ahead of the 2060 super by about five
and a half percent
and above the 2060 ko by a predictable
now 20
the 3060 ti has a 23 lead in this one
with the rest
mostly matching the previous scaling
this game could be played on a gtx 960
even today
as we showed in our recent revisit but
the competitive positioning of the
game itself increases the importance of
higher frame rate performance for
some players not everybody if you're not
good enough to care then well
cool but if you are looking for higher
performance than rainbow six siege is
the type of game you would use to figure
out what gpus are capable
of those higher frame rates at lower
resolutions at 1440p
the 36d ti falls to 237fps average
which is about the same frame rate as
the 2060 ko in the previous 1080p
chart the 3060 non-ti ends up at 186 fps
average
just behind the 1080 ti again
this card the 3060 shouldn't be an
upgrade ambition from 20 series cards in
general
although some of them are ahead of it
but especially not from a 2060 of any
kind super or not
it's just not a big enough jump for the
price but that's normal
it's more sensible if skipping a
generation and moving from say a 1060 or
a 960
although since the 3060 is 100 more
expensive than the 960 at launch which
is
more than inflation at this point it
does
feel like it's a different price
category than it used to be the rtx 2060
super
ended up just below the 30 60 xc black
once again
with about a 10 fps deficit 4k results
show the 3060 following the expected
ampere behaviors
higher resolutions tend to benefit the
newer ampere 30 series cards
as compared to most older nvidia
architectures or amd's rdna too
and so the 3060 secures a spot
alongside the gtx 1080 ti some things
never change
like the fact that the 1080 ti remains
the goat
the 2060 super trails the 3060 as does
the 5700 xt
and the 2060 ko allows the 360 a lead of
about 21
here the ti the 30 60 ti that is and
up would be needed if you want to hit
those higher refresh rates while still
playing at 4k
but anything above 60 here is fine it's
just not maybe as competitive red dead
redemption 2 is up now this one is among
the more demanding titles for gpus as a
counter to rainbow six
and it's useful as a measure of gpu
constraints even at lower resolutions
the rtx 3060 pulled a 92 fps average
result
with lows paced predictably behind we
didn't see any issues with the frame
time pacing while running this card
at least not any outside of the usual
comparative deficit in total war 3
kingdoms
the rtx 2060 ko held 77fps average
previously
with a gtx 1080 at 73 fps average
generally speaking users of gtx 1080
and better probably don't have much of a
reason to upgrade to a 3060.
you'd either need to climb the stack
higher or wait for
another generation for scale the 3060 is
19 ahead of the 2060 ko the 360 ti is 23
ahead of the rtx 3060 and just for an
amd comparison the rx 6800 is 49
ahead at 1440p the rtx 3060 does 71 fps
average about equal to the gtx 1080 ti
we'd reprise our old title from the 2080
super review
the one where we said we get it nvidia
you can make a 1080 ti but the 3060 is
actually significantly cheaper than a
1080 ti
it's an improvement despite equal
performance the rest of the chart falls
as predicted
the 2060 run 61 fps average the 360ti
runs 93
and the percent scaling is mostly the
same as the aggregate of the previous
results
the 4k result for red dead redemption 2
has the 30 60 below 60fps now at 44.
you could drop some quality settings to
help it a lot but at this point 4k would
best be paired with a different gpu
a higher-end one if you're not tied to
the idea of 4k in every game played
the 3060 might be an okay solution but
there are times when it's just not gonna
cut it like here
for cyberpunk 2077 we ran our standard
test at high settings and 1080p
the rtx 3060 ran at 80 fps average
placing it once again right between the
5700 xt
and the 1080 ti the 3060 ti has a 29
lead as a result of this that's similar
to some previous tests but a little on
the higher side
this configuration is playable on the
360 without any serious issues
well aside from the existing issues in
cyberpunk you can't fix those
horizon zero dawn's up now and we'll
just do 1080p for this one to keep it
short at this point we've established a
pattern and percentage scaling
expectation
so we sort of know where the 3060 will
fall on basically every game
at 1080p the rtx 3060 produced an
average fps of 113
tied with the 1080ti fdw3 and not
distant from the rx 5700xt
the 360 oc was somewhat meaningful here
getting us another 7
and moving to about 121 fps average
that's not bad for an rtx 30 series card
at the launch price
and by at the launch price we obviously
mean if you converted the msrp and usd
to bitcoin at a one-to-one ratio we'll
stop there for now on the rasterized
game performance
let's move on to rtx benchmarks and then
we'll talk power consumption quake 2
only has nvidia devices on
our charts right now the team recently
added wider vulcan support
but since we ran all these tests with
the rtx extensions previously
we'll stick to that for the remainder of
this gpu bench's life
and then upgrade later this is fully
path traced so rasterizing performance
isn't useful here
at 1080p the rtx 3060 ran at 66 fps
average
about the same as an rtx 2070 super or
an rdx 2080 fe
the 3060 ti leads by 19 a little below
the average leadership percentage in
rasterized testing but overall roughly
the same hierarchical position as before
at 1440p the rtx 3060 held 38 fps
average putting it in the same relative
position as the 1080p results
the 3060 ti here scales to 20 to 21
percent ahead and at 4k the 360 falls to
17 fps average
unplayable really but maintains the same
hierarchical positioning
the only interesting takeaway here is
that the 360 ti is now 22 percent ahead
so it's slightly gaining with each
resolution uptick when relying heavily
on rtx functions
the rt testing for shadow of the tomb
raider tends to balance better with
cards that have stronger rasterizing
advantages than they do ray tracing
advantages
like the 6800 and the xt cards because
in this game at least with this test
only rt shadows are present
so it's still mostly rasterized at 1080p
shadow of the tomb raider with rt
has the 30 60 at equivalent levels to
the 2070
and that allows the 3060 ti a lead of
about 27
the 3060 out does the 2060 ko
by 26 when rt is involved at 1440p the
rtx 3060's 51 fps average has it again
between the 2070 and 2070 super
with similar distance from the 2060 ko
and 3060 ti
as previously control is next we have
dlss on and off testing for some of
these tests
and amd's on here as well but ultimately
control is among the best dlss
implementations so far and will almost
certainly be played with dlss on with an
rtx card
the dlss on off testing is only useful
for determining how much dlss impacts
performance like for like
but we did that previously so we don't
need to do it again the 1080p results
have the 3060 running at 84fps average
with dlss on
the 3060 ti has a 31 lead over the
non-ti
but if we disable the lss the ti drops
to 68 fps average and is similar to a
2060 ko with dlss on
showing you the value of dlss when it
works well finally a quick look at
minecraft the rtx 3060 stock card ran 83
fps
average when dlss was on which is
basically required for minecraft rtx
and it positioned itself again between
the 2070 and 2070 super
at this point we've established that
this card will land between the two 2070
entries for
rtx performance power consumption is
last this is tested at the board level
and isn't power from the wall
we're testing only power consumed by the
gpu and the board including the vrm
efficiency losses
with the power virus workload the rtx
3060 xc black pulled 169 watts when
stock
or about 185 watts when overclocked this
aligns with the 12
offset offered on evga's v bios but
obviously would change depending on how
much
power a particular v bios allows the
card to draw if it has multiple power
connectors
it's possible that the manufacturer lets
you pull more than what we're seeing
here
the 3060 ends up below the 360 ti stock
draw by about 30
watts here in a gaming workload the rtx
3060 pulls about the same power as in
the power virus load when 100 loaded
meaning we're not waiting for the cpu
here this is normal and it's expected
behavior
but it helps to validate power numbers
in a real world gaming environment as
well
the rtx 3060 ti pulled 201 watts here so
spacing is about the same as before
the oc again boosted the 3060 by 10 to
15 watts
depending on when it was tested and this
aligns with the power
offset finally as we close out here just
a couple quick overclocking notes on
this
it was pretty easy to overclock it's the
same process as the other 30 series
cards we've already talked about all
that in the past and have hours and
hours of content on it
one key note though interestingly this
particular card and
not clear how much this is the xc black
and it's the bios versus all 30 60s
but this particular card it stopped
scaling
at a 100 to 175 megahertz offset
so anything from 100 to 175 for core
offset
did not produce a frequency change which
is
not completely abnormal but it's a
little bit odd because normally you
start crashing somewhere
in there but instead it looks flat and
so the first
reaction we had was maybe this is some
sort of
driver level let's not allow it to boost
higher than
is stable so that it doesn't crash thing
but that wasn't the case
what we ended up doing was typing in 250
megahertz offset 200 megahertz offset
and so forth and we found that
eventually it got past this weird wall
where it was not boosting at least in
the 3d mark applications we were
validating with
and finally at 200 and 250 it boosted
higher 250 was not stable
200 was as the offset but kind of
interesting and the
only real takeaway here is if you want
to play around with one of these for
overclocking
if you see it stop scaling at whatever
offset doesn't matter they're all
different because the baseline's
different but let's just say it stops
scanning at 100
but it doesn't crash at 125 or 150 it
might be worth keep
increasing that until it eventually does
crash because you might hit some weird
trigger point where it increases
as for a quick conclusion so in ray
tracing performance we found that it's
somewhere around a 2070
to a 2070 super in equivalent
performance
and obviously if you own basically any
20 series card
this isn't really an upgrade at best
it's a lateral move
to side grade if you had say a 2060.
uh versus the 2060 super and
rasterization performance on the 2060
in rasterization performance it's
anywhere from 11
to about 20 percent versus the 2060 ko
so that would be the cut down formerly
die that was turned into a 2060. and
it's uh anywhere from the the 20th to 30
percent lead in the
30 60 ti versus this 30 60. so that
gives you the
scale where it falls and ultimately for
value
it's we're not like we're not
particularly positive or negative
it's kind of meh and the reason we feel
that way
is it's pretty simple so we can't ignore
the value argument
it is compelling to ignore the value
argument right now
because as a reviewer you know that the
pricing
isn't necessarily going to be what it's
set to
but the reason we in particular are not
ignoring
the pricing of the card despite the fact
that the price will not hold that launch
is because the pricing of the card is
what nvidia sets and it indicates
nvidia's behavior
and nvidia's expectations and what
nvidia is trying to do with the cart and
regardless of the wider market
that's something we're very interested
in what is nvidia trying to do
with its positioning of this device and
our takeaway is that
the the price to performance increase is
simply not exciting enough to in any
other generation
make a strong recommendation for this
card it's fine it does well overall
but it's not exciting and in this market
that's all you need to sell
all you need is it's fine in some of
these games we're seeing a
one percent dollar increase for a one
percent performance increase which is
not progress it's stagnation and so
that's why we're met
on it in a couple other games it does a
little better than that
but not enough to really
make us do a headline that
is extremely positive about the device
so
overall we don't really have any major
complaints at least not about this
particular xc black model but
it's also somewhat disillusioning to
review devices when we already know
that they're in such short
availability versus the demand
regardless ultimately
this part of the conclusion is for the
future as this card comes into stock
what you need to know is 2070 2070 super
for rtx performance is where this falls
and then it's roughly a 1080 ti
to some of the 2080 class cards in
rasterization performance
with a 3060 ti offering about a mid to
mid 20s to low 30s percentage point
increase
over the 30 60. so if you're comparing
should i buy this or the ti
that's the range to look at it's about
30 higher bump in rasterization
pretty reasonable and for the most part
probably worth it if they're all at msrp
amd doesn't have an offering to compare
directly to this right now the closest
thing is the 6800
which is nearly 2x in price uh so we're
not going to make that comparison
but you can obviously pause on the
charts if you'd like to make it yourself
that's it for this one thanks for
watching subscribe for more as always
you can go to store.gamersexes.net or
patreon.com directly and get behind the
scenes videos
and we will see you all next time
[Music]